[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oula trenberth rogowska fabrice vous
avez envie de pisser mais pas du tout
c'est il est mort il est naze les foutus
pourquoi quel j a réagi sur twitter pour
la faire du livre d'échelle et en direct
qu'est-ce qu'il va regarder il est mal
merci à mon ami cyril hanouna 18 ans
trop jeune pour sortir une biographie
hashtag biographie non officielle il le
défend parce qu'ils sont amis faut il le
défend donc ça ne sert pas du tout vous
avez tout ce que vous avez gagné fabrice
avec cette histoire non cinq secondes de
kohler et à lomé en enfer
voilà servira de leçon aux coquin de
sort bertrand regarder je marie bigard
hier il répondait aux internautes sur
twitter
et alors et il a fait des blagues de cul
ce qu'on est alors bon c'est pas vrai
regardez il a balancé sur hanouna le
pire défaut d'hanouna quand il dit oui
je m'en occupe
tu peux être sûr que la réponse est non
et ben voilà on a un nouvel allié légal
bravo fabrice attendait ça fait me
rappeler que la semaine dernière j'ai
demandé à la lune à 6 l'an prochain et
pourrait blesser l'animé quelques
émissions tpm paix et m'a répondu oui je
m'en occupe
bonjour est ce qu'on voit si les
émissions bon bertron moi j'y vais pour
mon augmentation pour l'année prochaine
c'est oeil je m'en occupe
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous avez vu bertrand un article pure
médias cyril hanouna berthod voisin de
bureau d'antoine de caunes pour la
liberté mais parce que pourquoi nous
mais de quoi votre bureau jacques anouma
ce déplacement à aa
excusez moi vous avez berton chamerois
je le cherche partout et bertrand les
fabris même ses tubes mais j'ai passé le
bac ce matin l'épreuve de philo elle est
super ouais ouais bah écoutez le sujet
c'était l'artiste donne t'il quelque
chose à comprendre alors c'était quand
même page
j'ai fait une ligne j'ai répondu non
regardez cyril hanouna que la bad dont
là et quelques choses à comprendre la
comprend quelque chose et ça ça non plus
non plus et les paroles de boeck la pop
enough
ça veut rien dire donc la réponse est
non regardez c'est l'événement je pense
que vous allez avoir la moyenne avec ça
c'est ce que je me disais au début mais
j'ai suivi les conseils d'un journaliste
local c'était ce matin à la télé et ils
pourront sûrement peut-être mettre dans
leur copie cette célèbre citation d'un
fameux pakistanais lire c'est refuser de
moorea salut baba
en fait c'est ce soir à 20h50 croise les
doigts comme ça sans moi je vous ai
toujours préféré à bertrand bertrand il
est franchement il ya un melon à
pétanque à fabriquer là tous les deux
près que j'ai pas vu j'étais allongé par
terre depuis le début j'ai tout entendu
tout vu et toi combal ça fait trente
quatre épisodes que tu es plus dense au
fk rad et comme par hasard tu ramènes
ton que le jour et diffusion pour
l'émission late à sa reine avoir c'est
juste que je regardais les dernières sûr
quand même me suis calé un truc à
rajouter à apporter peut-être et sa
jeune et moi où tu vas regarde moi quand
j'te parle si tu comptes faire de
l'épisode de ce soir à une promo géante
pour ton émission battu peu de joueurs
jamais jamais ok mais mais audrey parti
je peux pas tout elle va chercher les
enfants de stars pour fabrice ouais j'ai
une excellente nouvelle a besoin c'est
ce que vous êtes bien près de chez lui
mais l'était il ya un vide où les
français ils veulent rester libre
regardez le fou la poule ce soir sur d8
qu'est ce que c'est ça fabrice basse et
la poule du jour je disais donc que j'ai
une excellente nouvelle à vous annoncer
figurez-vous que l'année prochaine
[Musique]
barbe fabrice de fait un peu flipper
journée s'est passée concernant m'aider
c'est l'oeuf ou la poule ce soir à 20h50
sur des beats lourds ok ressemblant